somebody who's very much alive is
six-time tony award-winning actress
audra mcdonald she is no stranger to
advocacy
she performs singing you home in 2018 to
benefit migrant families
separated at the border here's how she
i am sounds a long
deep breath and singing you
home
wherever you are right now
i'm bringing you closer
it's all i can do child
i am singing kind of sounds like me
after a warm-up
audra does that she makes it so
effortless now she's pushing for racial
justice as a founding member of black
theater united
the organization seeks to protect
members of the black theater community
and black lives across this country the
group calls for awareness
accountability advocacy and action
audra mcdonald audra mcdonald joins us
now hey andre very very good to see you
i love your voice nobody sounds like you
i'm good but not as good as you
andre this is the thing all of us were
deeply affected by the death of george
floyd and you said
that the theater community was eerily
silent
what did you mean by that does the
theater community normally speak up
yes the theater community comes together
to raise awareness for lots of issues
you know lgbtq
issues um you know the the issues with
immigration things like that but
um when the george floyd murder happened
um it just felt
a little too silent from the theater
community and a lot of us were very
aware of that and so
um that bothered my friend yes it did it
absolutely bothered me yes and my friend
lashants who was another great in
in the broadway community and i started
texting saying we need to do
something we need to make some noise we
need to sort of try and infect change in
whatever way we can
and so we got together with a bunch of
our friends norm lewis brian stokes
mitchell
anna davier smith vanessa williams
people like that and we thought let's
bring our community together and start
to raise awareness and and work on the
micro issue of systemic racism within
the theater community
and then the macro issue of systemic
racism within our country and so
you call it micro and macro audrey
explain the difference if you could
briefly well because i i think of it in
terms of you know if you have your
entire house on fire which is
systemic racism and racism and brutality
within the country
you can that's the macro and then the
micro is within our own theatrical
community making sure that we have more
diversity we have more representation
uh we have uh representation on and off
stage and in in
decision making and and um positions of
leadership and whatnot so that's the
micro
the theatrical community but the macro
is what's going on in our country so
we've been working
um we've been partnering with an
organization called fair count which was
founded by stacy
abrams to bring awareness to the fact
that
registering for the census is very
important and that black and brown
people are
um undercounted usually by about 10
percent
and it's even more so this year because
of covid but registering in the census
brings allocates over over a trillion
dollars
to communities and if those communities
aren't standing up and aren't counted
then they won't receive that money and
that money goes to resources for medical
and and and roads and schools and it's
about districting as well
um so that's why we wanted to raise as
much awareness as we can
we've started with a psa now to really
raise awareness i saw that psa
listen all the names you named are
people that we know billy porter of
course
vanessa warner yes he's one of the
people in our yeah yeah one of the
people in our psa too talking about
only one of me and how important it is
to register for the census but you also
included that
we're looking at the psa now but you
also included technicians and stage
managers
all the people that work behind the
scenes why was it important to include
that
group as well because that's also where
we're very much underrepresented
um within the theatrical community there
are very few people of color
in casting offices in publicity offices
in stage management in in the hair and
makeup unions in
in the in the carpentry unions and
that's just as important we need to see
representation
on all sides and on all fronts and we
also need to open up the pipeline to
make sure that
young people who want to have a career
in the theater
have access and resources to get there
and that means more mentorship
you know more paid internships things
things of that nature so
we've been doing a lot of work behind
the scenes as well meeting with lots of
different
theater companies throughout the country
really to just sort of raise awareness
and um sort of bring accountability
order when you have those conversations
it's anthony mason when you have those
conversations what kind of response are
you getting with the folks in power in
the theater community
um a lot of people are very open a lot
of people
realize that there is work that needs to
be done and sometimes
it means educating people we've also
been holding town halls too we had
cheryl and eiffel do one of our town
halls
um just to sort of address the moment
and the moment in history that we're in
and educate a lot of people who
um through the nature of the you know if
you want to call it white privilege or
whatever
haven't had to really look at this issue
at all and now it's this is a moment in
history where it's all staring us in the
face and
um it's a moment that we really need to
take advantage of and make sure that we
we make substantive change so glad
you're doing it but you're also doing
other things we have an exclusive look
of you playing aretha franklin's mom
in the biopic her mom barbara is her
name
what did you learn about aretha by
playing her mother and i'm wondering did
you bring your voice today because i
sure would like to hear
your favorite aretha franklin song
natural woman
gail it's early no one can sing like
aretha ever nam you can make me do it
nobody clock in the morning but you can
sing like audra and that's pretty damn
good
no my i have to say my favorite aretha
song is um
i'm gonna knock on your duck wrap
[Music]
give us one more line give us one more
line one more line please
i want to tell you baby changes i've
been going through
missing you sing along till you
come back to me that's what i
wanna do i'm not stepping on order
mcdonald's
no but it was wonderful getting a chance
to play her mother and getting a chance
to know a little bit more about aretha
by doing that her mother was a singer
yeah that was a wonderful singer
and very close to her children but um
unfortunately died when aretha was
just a little girl and so aretha didn't
get much time with her mother and and
yet
she had a huge impact on her life well
audra mcdonald i'm so glad to see you
you sound good
any time of the day thank you so much
for playing along and you look great
cheering you on always cheering you on
always good to see you thank you always
good to see you